[Music]
one of the reasons why computer security
is so hard is because you have to get
absolutely everything right in order to
have a secure system and there's lots of
different kinds of things you can get
wrong everything from your software was
buggy your passwords were too weak you
published your passwords accidentally
your hardware was insecure the user made
a mistake and fell victim to a phishing
attack and gave their credentials to a
foreign agent or a bad guy but all of
those things have to be done correctly
in order to have a secure system or it
might seem tempting to think everybody
has a cellphone so you could just use
your cell phone to do voting like we do
for American Idol or similar TV shows it
works for American Idol because nobody
cares all that much who wins or doesn't
win if you get the wrong outcome some
people will care but it won't affect
sort of the future of the country for
example it's not sensible to use cell
phones for voting for things that matter
national elections for example because
the the software on a phone is enormous
and very complicated and so
understanding that that code is correct
and actually counting all of the votes
appropriately would be a task that would
be so complex as to be infeasible you
could have you know the legitimate app
that is designed to correctly count the
votes for an election but somebody could
hack into that set of applications and
and implant bugs in a bunch of different
cell phones so that the final results
were not the actual intent didn't
actually capture the intent of all the
voters so a system for voting that
relies entirely on computers to do all
of the voting will never be secure
because you'll never have enough
confidence that the code that was
running on those computers correctly cal
counted the votes as the person who
voted intended there's always the chance
that there were bugs or that a hacker
came and changed the code or corrupted
the code to make the result be what the
hacker wanted instead of what the voters
wanted so one of the things to know
about how the u.s. election system works
is that voting machines are the purview
of states so every state has their own
process for deciding how what technology
to use to count votes
and so it's not that there's not a
monoculture where every single voting's
site has the same technology it's
determined on the state-by-state basis
so you have 50 different state
authorities at least who were deciding
what technology to use on for that
particular state and there are different
technologies in play one of the
technologies is just a touch screen
where you go and you tap the choices
that you want and it records it in the
computer program ten states currently
have that kind of technology and from a
cybersecurity perspective that
technology is terrible because what
computers do is exactly what they're
told to do by the last person who loaded
code onto the system I think people who
don't know very much about computers
tend to think that computers do the
right thing but in fact they just do
exactly what they're told to do so if
they're told to do the correct thing by
a person who has the authority to tell
them then that's great but that's often
not what happens the voting systems that
just have the touchscreen there's no way
of auditing what happened retroactively
Lia just a question of you know did the
system actually count it correctly you
don't know all you have at the end of
the day is the collection of totals so
somebody could have replaced the code
hacked in and made it count in a
slightly skewed way in a very skewed way
you really have no way of telling so
that technology is bad people pretty
much know that technology is bad and
it's being phased out so no one is
trying to buy more of these machines at
this point and they're no longer being
manufactured so we're trending in a good
direction as far as that's concerned a
different kind of machine are the
optical scanning machines where you fill
out it's kind of like a scantron form
from elementary school where you fill
out the multiple-choice questions on the
form and then the form is read
electronically and now the program
that's doing the reading has all the
problems of the system that I talked
about before where it is software that's
scanning and counting and could be buggy
could be corrupted by somebody who's
hacking in but you still have that paper
record so you can go back after the fact
and audit to confirm that the report
that the amount the total that was
reported was actually the correct and so
that that post-facto auditing capability
is really important most states use this
technology now some states have in place
an automatic auditing process so
independent of whether any candidate
asks for an audit they go and pick some
number of the voting districts and some
number of the ballots and they check to
make sure that the counting process was
correct I think probably the level of
auditing isn't sufficient there needs to
be broader auditing and more random
auditing going on but it's definitely a
step in the right direction the
principle the people in this who work in
this area talk about is they want to
make sure that they can guarantee the
results are correct even if a nefarious
person wrote the code that did the
counting so it has to work even if the
software was completely buggy and this
optical scanning reading technology
satisfies that characteristic because
even if the code that that does the if
it the counting of the scantron form is
buggy they can go look at the physical
forms and figure out that there was a
mistake and corrected using different
software so there's an audibility
capability that exists in that that kind
of technology that doesn't exist if you
have no paper trail so I think at this
point we kind of know how to do it from
a tactical point of view and the
question is getting the states all to
shift to that new kind of technology
[Music]